and this is the reality I I have young
guys I mean like young like Ballers NBA
like guys who are the like early 20s who
will hit me up want to take me out and
all of this and a lot of women who still
can carry a little bit as they get older
they're still in shape they're getting
hit up by these young guys and you think
you still have it because these guys
will want to sleep with you they'll even
take you out there I mean they'll even
buy you something to do they're not
going to marry you and a lot of women
just like the glamor of it and they feel
like they still got it and they don't
realize these guys are just using you
for easy sex and so because they're
sleeping with you and they're attracted
to you that translates in your mind that
I got it like I'm still in the game